muy buenos días pues vemos una gran
afluencia de público en este centro de
votación más grande del país y como se
lo decía el presidente saliente y bando
que ya ejerció su derecho a voto lo hizo
en la mesa número uno que está ubicada
en el capitolio nacional aparte del
presidente también tenemos a muchas
personas acá en el centro de corferias
votando desafiando el clima lluvioso en
la ciudad de bogotá y en el resto de las
12 mil puestos de votación con más de
112.000 en mesas desplegadas a lo largo
de todo el territorio nacional las mesas
estarán abiertas hasta las 4 de la tarde
pero ya estuvieron abiertas durante el
transcurso de la semana para alrededor
de un millón de personas que votan en el
exterior
daniela y en las elecciones pasadas de
marzo en las legislativas hubo una
abstención de alrededor del 45 por
ciento como se prevé que sea esta
jornada
bueno pues tenemos un coeficiente
electoral de 38 8 millones de personas y
tenemos una estadística de las últimas
elecciones presidenciales las 5 que han
ocurrido en lo tiene el transcurso del
siglo 21 es del 53% la abstención esto
quiere decir que los votos no llegan al
20% a la 20 millones de votos en todo el
territorio nacional se espera entonces
que en esta jornada se venza ha sido uno
de los grandes retos que se pensaba esta
altísima abstención electoral recordemos
38,8 millones de personas un millón de
personas en el exterior y a partir de
las 4 de la tarde inicia un pre conteo
que la registraduría nacional ha dicho
que dos o tres horas después iniciarán o
se entregarán en los resultados de estas
votaciones esto después de que en las
elecciones del 13 de marzo de los
comicios legislativos hubiera varias
irregularidades denunciadas por parte de
los diferentes partidos sobre la labor
del pensador en nacional